hey guys how's it going justine here
welcome to the what is in my purse video
now this is a pretty requested video and
i did one a long time ago with my sister
brianne who
really carries some strange things in a
purse most of the stuff that i carry my
purse is sort of everyday things that
i'm gonna need so before we go into this
um be sure to leave you a comment and
let me know what is in your purse and if
you guys have what's in my first videos
please leave them as video responses to
this video and if you happen to be a
dude feel free to
um if you have a purse or a man purse or
a book bag or
whatever you carry stuff
in you can leave it as a video response
and comment as well i will not judge you
okay first of all this is uh probably
one of my new favorite purses because i
like to have like a separate little
pocket where i can just always have
access to my phone and that's what we
have the first thing is my phone um
second i actually just threw this in
here just now because they almost always
carry a water with me
just reminding them thirsty
because you never know you may get
stranded somewhere and you may be
thirsty sunglasses
always very important to keep the
sunnies handy
i don't really carry any makeup except
for this it's a smashbox photo finish
foundation primer i like to put it over
top of my face if i'm getting shiny
probably easier to carry around a
compact with a mirror but when i need a
mirror i use my iphone front facing
camera
whatever
vlogging camera this is actually my old
old vlogging camera but
mistakes have been made with my new one
so oops
okay i got a lot of cords this is a
mini usb
i also have a micro usb an iphone
charging cable now these are all to
charge random things this is what i
charge them with now you may be
wondering okay why do you have all these
cords
um
well the one cord charges my iphone the
other one charges my verizon wi-fi card
and the third
charge is my gopro which is in here
you never know when you're gonna need to
go pro on the go
extra little drink i normally am
drinking the revel berries but i can't
find any anywhere in l.a oh no my straw
is bent i can't drink my goyaki without
a straw so i have to go find another
straw
i don't know
headphones oh and another
charger for my fitbit this little
charging brick charges everything
chapstick chapstick
ipad
gotta always carry it my criteria for
purses nowadays are
does it fit an ipad mini
um this is some sunglass lens cleaner i
actually use this to not only clean my
sunglasses but i use it to clean my ipad
and my iphone so i just threw a little
spray spray spray and then i used this
little teex bag
actually my shoes came in this little
bag so i use this little bag to just
clean it
um
these are my favorite little shark clips
i just use these to clip my hair
sometimes especially when i'm driving i
hate when my hair is in my face so i'll
just
clip it
a snack
sometimes i get really hungry so i
always have to keep a snack in case my
blood sugar drops and i don't want to
pass out little tiny lotion that i stole
from the w hotel i always steal hotel
lotions i don't really steal that i mean
they give them to you and i just take
them home with me
some gum
sharpie
my wallet i don't want to show you any
my information but there's a wallet
sd card just in case my other sd cards
get full some hair ties i think that's a
lot
oh last but not least
my nintendo ds because not only do i
need to collect the mies i need to
collect the coins
so
that's what's in my purse
i guess it's kind of interesting
considering the amount of random crap
that i do have in my house let me know
what you guys have in your purse or
whatever it is to carry i look forward
to seeing everything that you guys have
um let me know what the most random
thing is that you thought that i had in
my bag and don't count don't count the
screwdriver because i don't usually have
a screwdriver in my purse
i don't really know where that came from
i think i was bringing it from
downstairs upstairs and just stuck in my
purse either way let me know what video
you guys would like to see me make next
and i will see you guys back here
another day
bye
we're both a little sleepy today so
don't judge